they're ringing their bells now with
their victory blurs who'd be wringing
their hands it's going to be absolute
nightmare with a tiny majority and stop
moved for five years unlike Harold
Wilson they can't escape and go for an
early election that have to sway
two-thirds of MPs to do that so they're
going to have a real Calvary of a
journey on this they're going to find
absolutely miserable and you can see the
DUP leaders and the nutcases on the back
benches of the Tory party preparing for
it already they're salivating at the
idea of the blackmail they'll be able to
get into thinking there's a real chance
that labor could win the next election
in 2020 yes I think those commentators
are saying it's going to take ten years
so completely misguided if Labour makes
the right choice and it understands why
it lost then it can easily win next time
it's a good chance to be an opposition a
good chance to win a big majority next
time round and won't your view did it
lose I think it's perfectly clear it
wasn't the campaign everyone says their
campaign was the best it wasn't dead
Miliband everyone seems to think it
would have ended very well on the
campaign trail so it was a fairly simple
thing they tried to run from the left
and since 1945 the Labour Party has not
been able to win from the left and I
don't think it ever will be able to some
people in the Labour Party thought the
center ground had shifted to the left it
hadn't it's in the same place so when we
run from the center left we win when we
don't we won't and so next time round we
have to adjust that problem is that
people associate the centre-left with
new labour I am with Tony Blair who
because of his foreign adventures has
become toxic in British politics but I
think surely we can now move on from all
of that I mean it's been some time
caught hanging over us yes but took
Ortiz about the past this is choice of
the new labor leaders about the future
you choose someone who comes from the
centre-left who understands why we lost
who can put forward a convincing vision
of the future and can win that's what we
need to have it's no good being a
perfect opposition and polishing our
ideological credentials it does
absolutely no good for the people we
represent people we represent 12
government and a government with a
decent majority how would that for
example help you get Scotland back where
a party to the left of Labor has
supplanted leg well I have my doubts
about the SMP being left I mean my
experience SNP's left and right it's a
bit like the Liberals they try and be a
bit of each and when they have to go
into government it becomes a bit of a
problem because they have to choose
between the two things so I think you
may well see this as the SNP high-water
mark I'm glad they're celebrating now
because I suspect as they have to make
difficult choices up
north of the border they're going to
find themselves suffering both north and
south of the border so if you look at
labor have you chosen a candidate yet no
no I haven't chosen a candidate I shrink
my support be a kiss of death but I just
hope that someone sensible wins this and
I think some of my new generations I say
I think we need to move down a
generation the same way that Tony Blair
is moving on from New York Erich Mielke
an it was moving on from Michael foot we
need to move on to a younger group of
people say not event Cooper or Andy
Burnham I think we want to have people
who aren't associated with the old
battles people who come with clean hands
if you like and I mean that looks like
Chuck Ramona or Liz Kendall or maybe
some people talking about Trish from a
hunt I mean do you see all of those is
viable I I think someone who sets out a
convincing analysis of why be one who
sets out a convincing vision for how we
can win next time round and that younger
generation would be the right person to
choose and does whoever takes our all
have to do what David Miliband was
planning on doing which is to say yes we
did get some more economic decisions
role particularly from the mid 2000s
onwards to be honest I by 2020 we're
going to be looking at a row of a
different sort of equation assuming the
five-year Parliament rule holds it
that's not really going to be the game
at the same time you know you only have
to look at the question time in Leeds
it's clearly something that's on the
public mind that they can't trust label
with the economy yes but that's the
issue I mean the reason we lost is
because they went into the voting booths
and they thought do we trust this party
with gay economy and that's what we had
both emitting that you didn't make
mistakes that you didn't to use the
cliche repair the roof when the Sun was
shocked I mean the idea that the labour
party cause the global economic crisis
is ridiculous now did we get it at
Britain's problems did we get everything
right in terms of economic policy and
government no we didn't we did try and
spend too much in certain area but
already is now you've lost a selection
is there time whether it's a bum rap or
not to simply say yes we got it wrong
and this while we're going to do I think
it's part of a bigger picture of
establishing economic credibility we
went worked incredibly hard to get
economic credibility in 1997 and to
maintain it in government we need to get
it back that will be one part of it but
there'll be a much bigger canvas on
which they had to draw a new economic
also going to be elections for london
mayoral candidate this year and deputy
leader with Tommy Watson Caroline Flint
and possibly stella creasy saying
they're going to run would you care to
pick a candidate for either no I would
not I I mean I'm focused on how do we
pick up ourselves off this defeat work
out why we lost and make sure that it
doesn't happen again particularly at the
national level normal Bell thank you
thank you